we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
here's a smart caller this caller thinks
he may know the truth about the latest
Trump indictment listen to this hi David
I think this indictment of trump on
seven plus counts it's just a
distraction from Obama Gates I mean
there's still so many
unanswered uh questions uh and and
there's such a mountain of evidence
that's right too like why are people
focusing on things like uh sexual
assault serges and uh steel and
classified documents when they could be
focusing on Obama gays absolutely
Obama gate is the biggest crime of the
century I don't know of which century
maybe this one maybe last one it's never
really clear Obama gate is
extraordinarily serious I also don't
know what it is and clearly all of this
stuff that's going on you know a jury
finding Trump responsible for sexual
assault and defamation of Eugene Carroll
a 37 count indictment involving pictures
of classified documents around Trump's
toilet like a fort
all of it is a trumped up for lack of a
better term distraction
from Obama gate which they don't want
you to know about all right let me put
my brain back in on the bonus show today
the Supreme Court has unexpectedly
upheld a provision prohibiting racial
gerrymandering some are surprised by it
Unabomber Ted Kaczynski has died in
prison
reportedly by Suicide at age 81 we will
discuss the story and his legacy we will
also talk about the White House being
accused of flag code violations because
of their pride month display this is
getting so pathetic from these folks who
have no issue putting the flag on a
bandana that says Maga and doing the
exact same thing now all of a sudden
they're concerned because of the pride
flag okay all of those stories and more
will be on today's bonus show the United
States will be the first nation to land
an astronaut on ours we are taking the
bonus show to Nars and Beyond you can
sign up at joinpakman.com you can use
the coupon code
indicted again that's right indicted
again a self-explanatory coupon code use
it save a bunch of money get the bonus
show we will see you then